[Music]
there's a cognitive psychologist by the
name of Justin Barrett who did a series
of really fascinating studies about the
way in which people think about God he
asked a group of devoutly religious
people Muslims Jews Christians Buddhists
Hindus he basically gave them a form to
fill out about the ways in which they
think about the divine and for the most
part what he found was that they
answered in theologically correct ways
when talking about God as being say
omniscient or omnipresent but then he
began to engage the same subjects in
conversation he asked them to start
describing in regular language how they
think about God and what he discovered
is that almost every single person when
forced to start talking about God
violated those core theological
principles of God being for instance
omnipresent and omniscient
in fact what he discovered is that the
more they talked about God the more it
sounded like they were describing some
person that they met on the street and
this goes to a fundamental aspect about
the way that we think about the divine
whether we are ourselves believers or
not and that is that unconsciously
we can't help but to imagine God as
essentially a divine version of
ourselves when we conceive of God we
unconsciously innately impose upon God
our own personality our own virtues our
own vices our own strengths our own
weaknesses we project upon God our own
biases and bigotries we implant in God
human characteristics human personality
human desires all along with humans with
superhuman powers and so as a result
what we really do again whether we're
aware of the
or not is we divin eyes ourselves if you
believe in God
then what you believe in is something
that is by definition utterly unhuman
and so the question becomes how do you
talk about that thing how do you think
about that thing how do you form a
relationship with something that is
utterly unhuman
well the way you do so is by humanizing
that thing in fact the entire history of
human spirituality can be viewed as one
long intimately linked and remarkably
cohesive narrative in which human beings
increasingly humanize the divine until
of course in the person of Jesus God
literally becomes a human being that I
think more than anything else explains
why Christianity is the most successful
religion in the world because in a way
it scratches an unconscious itch that we
all have our brains work in such a way
that we are compelled to conceive of God
in human terms it's an impulse that we
that were born with it goes back deep in
our human evolution what Christianity
says is well God is not just human like
God is literally a human being and
imagine how appealing that notion is
because if you want to think about God
you know it's it's an impossible task
it's it's a it's it's so difficult to
conceive of something like God and what
Christianity says is that it's not that
hard actually you want to know what God
is like imagine the most perfect person
perfectly good perfectly compassionate
perfectly sinless that's God that's a
pretty easy thing to imagine
[Music]